en cuanto a lo que se refiere a
democracia por ninguno de los dos y
ninguno de los candidatos ofrece muchas
garantías y con fujimori por representa
pues son un régimen efectivamente que
que propició un golpe de estado no y
además ella misma tuvo un comportamiento
muy discutible y poco democrático cuando
éste las tras las elecciones pasadas
donde su bancada pues en el congreso se
y con rabia en buena parte a torpedear
la gestión del presidente electo pero
pablo kuczynski no le vamos a aceptar
muy pero muy de manera en no aceptar
realmente los resultados
y en el caso de el castillo pues
claramente esta vinculación con sectores
extremistas izquierda tampoco son muy
tranquilizadores entonces eso
desarrollen peor de los escenarios en
esta elección dos candidatos que no
ofrecen garantías en términos
democráticos y que tal vez la diferencia
bueno y además el caso de keiko fujimori
efectivamente ha llegado también a casos
de corrupción pero en el caso de
castillo pues su el señor es de su socio
el líder de perú libre es el señor se
ronda al emir cerró el también ha sido
condenado por corrupción y en segunda
instancia entonces bueno por ese lado él
tampoco puede ofrecer muchas garantías
entonces sí pues es una elección
terrible en ese sentido y evans eso
viene desde la primera vuelta donde
efectivamente
y de alguna manera pues era realmente
algo así en una elección